c'est quoi êtes-vous ya plein de
chansons pour les femmes aujourd'hui
tati joue mais ça c'est qui ça c'est
qu'il s'agit
[Musique]
allez enfin jeu celui qui gagne j'ai
fait un énorme cadeau braathen ma mère
les voilà en petite blind test comme ça
mais c'est en déniant demir un point
pour casillas est parti à l'autre
[Applaudissements]
les gars
je voulais
j'adore s'cusez moi peut mettre un peu
plus de son sur athènes ou à mers les
bains aisée quoi les enceintes là mon
frère un boulet à les enrichir à chier
des bulles carrier mettez moi un outil
j'adore ma préférée
[Musique]
donc
change avec rageux
l'ajout de la monnaie rob vos
quand tu centre j'oublie j'ai plus le
moindre souci j'ai le mal qui brille
[Applaudissements]
regardant la phase qui me ramène à la
case départ là où je suis parti
non mais tu aimes à l'autre le démagogue
peux-tu faire défaut le gardien
[Musique]
oh
derrière
[Musique]
la souris avec la
la dame
il y a
[Musique]
le grand gagnant les benjamins comme
benji l'offre mon chéri je vous offre
votre prochain mariage
[Musique]